hello everyone thank you for coming to
my speech today so some of you may know
me from the London machine learning
practice Meetup
can I have a show of hands up who's been
to one of them okay so we've got a few
people now my presentation today is
going to be autobiographical so sample
size of one don't take it too seriously
so Who am I I'm a data scientist with
nanotech galaxies we do machine learning
algorithms to analyze radiological
imagery so matter we do we use machine
learning to predict diagnosis that would
have been done by radiologists if he was
looking at a at an x-ray for example so
quite complicated stuff now six months
ago I was a project manager for a
development company now one might think
how the hell did I get to become a data
scientist from a project manager now one
caveat is that I'm actually a
mathematician so that helped a bit but
from the time I did my degree I spent
two years working in a completely
non-technical industry with people who
do not know how to format an Excel
spreadsheet let alone compile a machine
learning model so why did i hack why did
I decide to do it so quickly why did i
hack my career now I had a bit of a
falling out with the academia when I was
back at school I've always been called
the smart but lazy student I've always
done my assignments at the last moment
I've never been well have been some of
the teacher's pet but not all of them
definitely so when it got to university
it got worse so I suddenly realized that
wait a minute I don't actually I'm not
in love with what I'm doing I'm not
particularly excited about half of the
subjects I'm falling asleep at 10:00
a.m. even if I had 10 hours of sleep the
night before
so even though was I'm a big fan of
maths and a big fan of science I decided
not to do a PhD when I graduated I
realized that I wasn't going to survive
it and as I'm seeing from a lot of my
friends doing their PhDs they're just
barely surviving it themselves so I
decided to become a data scientist about
a year ago when I watched a TED talk by
Jeremy Howard the CEO of analytic who
are actually now our main competitors at
the moment and I was really inspired I
finally realized that my long-standing
interest in the sciences and in the
newest in neuroscience as well could be
made into a career which is a III
research machine learning but how do you
actually do that when I started
researching into degrees I realized that
well it's going to take me one year for
a master's and three years for a PhD if
I get the funding or if I get accepted I
quit my job November last year if I were
to go for a master's degree it would
have cost me 28,000 pounds as a non-eu
student and I would have and I would
have started in November this year
not not now even so what I've still been
in my job which I hated not knowing what
my future is suffering from uncertainty
and facing a large bill from the
university as well as the living
expenses so I decided not to do it I
quit my job and I saved some money and I
just devoted six months to learning to
teaching myself to become a data
scientist as quickly as possible why
would this even work as an approach now
because everybody knows that we've got
these universities everybody wants to go
and do a degree because that's what
people normally do well from practice
one might might suspect that in fact a
lot of social systems are hackable you
don't generally have to
the rules if you are if you actually
become a bit scientific and a bit of a
statistician you can take calculated
risks and calculated inconveniences that
other people decided not to take or were
too afraid to take and actually find a
much faster route know why does our
society support higher education in
general the standard answer to that is
because while there's social pressure
because you're expected to do a degree
but that wasn't the case a hundred years
ago nobody graduated from school they
hunted like in the 19th century what he
had was people transitioning through
labour people transitioning through
family connections or a pure talent and
being noticed why do we now do our
degrees well one might say that while we
need a more structured approach we need
to actually and this is valid we knew we
need primary education we need people we
need children to be guided into their
careers - and have some standardized
base from which to build upwards but an
economist called Robin Hanson also has
another idea specifically about
University and higher education it's not
about social pressure it's about social
signaling it's about prestige it's like
wearing a Prada bag or a Louboutin heels
for girls so what you're actually doing
is by having a degree you are telling
the employers that well you've been good
enough to get it into this university
you've been it's like a label that is
easy to validate and is easily
noticeable so this is why the new
equilibrium is that this generally
people go into higher education now we
don't just try to transition into doing
things straight after school or even
after primary school would have been
done even fifty years ago but the cost
of that is increasing so if you look at
cost of Education in the state between
1980s and 2014 it has skyrocketed
the average student is now facing an
insurmountable debt if they if their
family obviously isn't rich enough to
pay for them
so this situation looks a bit like the
tulip trade in Amsterdam so the markets
got so much out of control we've got a
bubble here quite obviously and because
we've got a bubble clearly it's not a
very good idea to buy into that there
must be another way
we don't have you're not in an absolute
need of something but let's say what if
in fact education gives you some value
what if it's not just about social
signaling well there is some evidence
against that there was a - researchers
called Schmidt and hunter did a
meta-analysis of the best predictors of
success of an employee after interviews
as per employer now the best predictors
are obviously work sample test how well
have you seen them do their job do their
job
IQ because the higher the IQ the faster
person would generally learn employment
interviews but just the structured once
the unstructured ones are far way down
the list so if you have a standardized
approach if you asked everybody the same
questions you can weed out the people
who are worse and pick out the people
who are better job experience number 14
the fact that you have 10 were 10 years
of work experience doesn't say much
about how good you're going to be at
your job even in your existing industry
and number 16 we've got years of
education it explains 10% of the
variance in job performance
so really if if you have spent five
years on after University on PhDs and
postdocs it really doesn't say much
about you in real terms
so even if you might get an easier time
finding a job you're not going to get an
easier time keeping a job and moreover
it doesn't guarantee that you're going
to find a good job or a job that you're
going to enjoy this is something that's
going to be controlled by other factors
like how intelligence your hope is
persistent you are how much have you
practiced 10,000 hours anybody hover has
anybody read Malcolm Gladwell's outliers
there you go so it's not about it's not
about intelligence alone it's not about
practice alone but the two together make
a winning recipe and they do not depend
on where you went to uni obviously the
the two are correlated so if you've got
persistence and intelligence you will
you would have gotten to a better unit
but maybe you just lucked out or maybe
you work you gamed the school's
educational system which is very
different from actual industry and
that's allowed you to get good grades
and get into a good university but
writing an essay a week to a pre-defined
crazy a set of criteria isn't the same
as putting software into production at
two weeks notice and you don't even know
what it's going to be yet so I really
get our betting on education isn't a
very good idea in general assuming you
know what you're doing though ouch so
what does it mean for me first of all as
I've already said I didn't want to pay
28 K on a on tuition fees alone these
are the real figures by the way this is
how much masters and machine learning
and statistics cost at UCL and also a
similar degree at Imperial they all cost
about twenty eight thousand pounds and
they are all so few and far between if
you want to go for a boot camp
there is one ie private education which
is more practically oriented there are a
few but there is as far as I'm aware
there is only one decent course in
London and they take 20 people at a time
which is yes which is the general
assembly course if you've got
if you've got a PhD you might be able to
go for science to data science through
the ASI fellowship but they do require
PhD so an extra three years of work
actually because of the number of
applicants who already hold those
degrees you will be at a disadvantage
when employing those or when applying
for those when you only hold the
bachelors like I do now as I said
starting date the cost of education is
not just monetary at the moment there is
no way in within the UK educational
system to advance your degree to do it
faster you have to plow through the
three years if you're doing a bachelor's
you have to you can do a PhD faster you
can't do your masters faster so if you
actually want to minimize the cost and
pay lower tuition fees you're not
allowed to do that because the
admissions committee the exam committee
meets once a year and they don't care
that you want to get a job faster so you
you don't get the flexibility you're
your starting date so later and the
industry is developing now there is high
demand now for data scientists there may
not be in three years time there might
be a glutton three years time so purely
from economical perspective I the cost
of doing a degree is quite high and
obviously there's also the question of
getting funding for a PhD or getting a
good advisor for a PhD so not being
forced to write on a topic that you
don't don't care about and that maybe
two people will read and really doesn't
guarantee improved career prospects you
might get a job but you will be stuck in
it for ten years
if you can't demonstrate your ability by
other things by things other than your
degree so how do you actually go about
it first of all things not to do hope
that a university degree is the ticket
to a rosy future have already seen that
it's not expect to do it all on your own
so my people might have seemed that okay
since I decided not to go to university
I just became a lone wolf sat down with
and just read and read and read and
coded encoding encoded and there Here I
am now first of all when you're starting
you don't know what you don't know you
need feedback one thing that defines
good education and good educational
outcomes is how much feedback you get
and how frequent it is students who
students who sit a test before they even
start reading the material and are
graded on it will then learn the
material better but as as being scored
by a subsequent test compared to those
who haven't had a test previously so
it's good to jump in at the deep end
it's good to understand what you do not
know it's good to go and do a hackathon
even if you're only a beginner because
then you will actually get glimpses of
what professionals are doing
universities do not tell you that
moreover they don't give you the state
of the art techniques until you get
three years into your degree into a PhD
when you're expected to gradually find
it out on your own
sitting in an office not talking to
people so don't expect to do it on your
own not just from the perspective of
understanding things but also from the
side of time management when you're on
your own is very easy to procrastinate
if you're sitting reading a book you get
your favorite shows comes on you're
going to watch the show for two hours
instead of reading the book if you're
seated sitting and reading the book with
a friend less likely so if your are due
to present on that book to a group of
200 people the following day maybe even
less likely so a good thing about not
doing things on your own is that you
have social pressure you've got social
responsibility to stick to your goals
and generally humans are very bad at
sticking to their goals when there
aren't they're the only ones watching
when there are the only ones assessing
themselves you need external input not
allow for a margin of error
you don't when you're starting a
software development project on a novel
on an app like developing a completely
new product how many of you have
actually managed to do it exactly on
time as initially defined how many did
not raise your hands there we go
so do not expect it to be the same when
you're doing self-education it's a
complex project you don't want to when
you make a first estimate x 3 and expect
it to take this much this long similarly
when you're pitching to an investor and
they see you of your financial your
financial plan they they divide it by 3
because people tend to be very
optimistic about how long it's going to
take them to do something and how much
they're going to progress in it or how
little little rather don't burn your
bridges if you're jumping into a risky
into a risky project into a risky
venture realize that it's risky
there is always certain odds of you
failing don't completely burn your
bridges don't completely kind of tell
your boss to go away and leave you alone
and you're never coming back make sure
to leave to stay friends and to get
avenues to be able to come back into
your ol industry should you wish so or
should you need more time or should you
run out of money always have a plan B
because everything that you're doing the
fact that you're hacking through things
mean that you're taking a riskier
approach it's some more it's a higher
payoff but it's also a higher risk and
the more and the higher there was
usually the higher the risk so you're
are likely to fail and you will fail
repeatedly until you finally succeed and
when you finally get to interviewing
don't hope that the employer can read
your mind so you've learned all of these
things on your own but that you don't
have a degree you need a way of still
providing this social signaling so that
other people know that you're competent
now
I'm going to go through these points
what did I do
in the end first of all set a realistic
time frame I put aside a year two for
this project equivalent to a master's
degree I knew I was going to be most
likely able to do it faster but I had
enough money to sustain myself for a
year and this way I knew I didn't have
to rush I knew I didn't have to despair
when I failed repeatedly until I finally
succeeded don't trust yourself with
sticking to deadlines I didn't sit and
read the book in my own I didn't go into
a Coursera course and hope that I knew
everything I signed up to as many
meetups as I could before I started my
own then I started my own now I'm
responsible for giving a presentation to
200 people looking expectantly at me and
it's kind of embarrassing if I don't
know what I'm talking about so this give
me this gives me deadlines I joined my
classmates at UCL for a study group on a
statistics textbook which is by the way
the main text for the machine learning
masters at UCL so if you create a
structure around yourself then you're
able to replicate what University would
give you you create yourself deadlines
and more importantly you create costs
for missing those deadlines having a
cost is very important if you don't have
anyone around you who will you if you
don't have a group around you that will
penalize you for not sticking to your
deadlines there are services that allow
you to make a bet where you you pay the
money if you don't stick to your
deadline they pay to a charity you hate
like Trump supporters so if you don't
learn data scientists science Trump will
win make a study plan so the first thing
I did was scope the scope the area of my
study figure out what are the latest
developments when did it all start turns
out it didn't start that long ago even
though the first neural network were
networks were developed quite a while
ago in this
seize the computing power has only been
sufficient in the past for five years to
do it and they on any kind of large
scale so I was like we're all lucky
there because the there is still a lot
of scope for growth this is similar to
what happened when the internet first
started getting high speeds when people
suddenly realized that oh you can have
internet on your mobile what can you do
with that apps lots of apps so you need
to scope what you don't know and make a
study plan make don't stick to it too
rigidly because you will find out new
things on the way but at least you need
to have an idea of how much you're going
to have to cover and when the deadlines
should be finally prepare for
uncertainty you don't know that you're
going to be capable of learning
everything in the time you have planned
for yourself some things will naturally
be difficult you will Plateau sometimes
sometimes you'll get stuck with code or
sometimes you'll get stuck with setting
up your AWS server were installing cafe
on your laptop whatever allow for these
things there's as with project
management when as when you're putting a
new product a new piece of software into
production there's always delays this is
exactly the same as a project manager
luckily I've suffered more than my fair
share of that even even though it was in
another industry so I knew all too well
that I can't plan to do everything
exactly on time so allowed for twice as
much time as I was as I was expecting to
spend willpower self study requires
willpower and being organized well power
is a limited resource we are often told
that ok you just need to try harder well
yes you can try harder but for a limited
amount of time you can't just go and
sprint for three hours straight because
your body is going to run out of energy
your muscle is going to run out of
oxygen your it's gonna stop working your
body will refuse to keep on going and do
this so your brain is exactly the same
you're not going to be able to exercise
willpower to unlimited lengths so you
need to be able to measure how much you
have and how much you can realistically
spend per day exercising it don't expect
to sit down and study for eight hours a
day if you've quit your job
because you want studying is a much more
intensive exercise it's a much higher
cognitive load than sitting and doing a
task you're used to do don't expect to
be able to do that allow for four hours
do more if you can external
reinforcement and social cost of default
by the way social cost of default is how
they sold micro-financing if when
lenders tried to lend to a sink try to
implement micro lending by lending to a
single person the defaults were
skyrocketing there were like 50 in the
tens of percents though 50 60 70 %
because if the person didn't pay back
the loan nothing happened to them well
they got told off by the lender but who
cares however when they started lending
to groups of people
say six or seven people come together
and lend some money to do a social
enterprise or whatever the default rates
drop to 2% this is what you get with
corporate lending for nice large
corporations with millions of turnover
why because if one person defaults the
other six have to pay their debt now
once you've got a social cost of default
you look less likely to try and cheat to
try and not pay back your debts because
there is a high cost of doing that you
will be humiliated by your peers
humiliation is much higher it is a much
better deterrent than losing money or
even losing your job therefore try to
try to introduce as many deterrence as
possible to not sticking to your goal
and finally limit your choices humans
are not good
dealing with multiple choices especially
when they're allowed to change their
mind they did a study where they gave
people a choice of two images to post us
to keep now some of those people just
chose a poster and took it home
the other half chose a poster and a week
later they were allowed to change their
mind and swap the poster now when later
on they were questioned about how happy
they were with the choice those who are
allowed to change their mind were
significantly less happy than those who
are not so you will need to if you plan
to transition into a new industry you
will need to manage your mood you will
need to manage your state of mind
because if you get depressed if you get
dis encouraged you're less likely to
continue the happier you are with your
choice the more likely you are to have a
good mood and have the energy to study
therefore limit your choices don't give
your limit your uncertainty as much as
possible because you will have a lot
anyway so if you've decided to do
something commit to it do it for as far
as you for as long as you can until well
until you fail beyond reasonable doubts
then you can change your mind
but don't try to just move between
different strategies every single day or
today I'm learning one topic but maybe I
should learn another one so maybe I
should learn regression or maybe I
should learn XML or maybe I should learn
Java whatever so if you if you keep John
if you keep changing your mind it's not
a very good idea because it won't just
affect your productivity in terms of
learning progress it will also affect
your mood now time management techniques
Pomodoro who knows about Pomodoro
Technique okay so in sufficiently many
poor Medora technique means that you set
an alarm for 20 minutes and you commit
to working for those 20 minutes and then
you have a five-minute break or
ten minute break that's where you know
that you're not facing hours and hours
of work because you will you have a when
you have a long project the largest
mental deterrent is knowing that you
don't know when it's going to finish
this way you have manageable chunks so
you work for 20 minutes then you have a
break then you reset the time I work
with 20 more minutes then you have a
break again so one thing that it does it
prevents overworking during the break
you get to stress you get to stand up
and you must obey by the rules you can't
overwork you can't work for 30 minutes
instead you must stick by 20 minutes and
when especially when you have a tight
deadline this is a very efficient
technique because it forces you to do
something in those 20 minutes you can't
just sit down and look on facebook
you're you have to be focused on your
work and it's only 20 minutes so it
doesn't hurt that much and you know that
you're going to have a nice break
afterwards space repetition don't try to
do hours like 10 hour chunks of work in
one go another example from education
when students are learned for three
hours straight before an exam they
perform significantly worse than when
they learned for one over a for one hour
or one hour over three days in fact to
perform similarly to the three hours
they only had to spend about less than
two hours time with spaced repetition
when it was over a few days so don't try
to cram it's not a very good idea if you
manage to space your practice over a few
days you will learn more and you will
have to spend less time doing it so why
not do it you'll get more time watching
your TV series afterwards anyway a value
of sleep when sleep-deprived you suffer
your working memory suffers your
concentration suffers you perform
significantly worse so it doesn't
actually pay to sleep less in order to
work more that doesn't help
you're more likely to your willpower
suffers the first this is one of the
main problems with investment
banks where people work 9:00 a.m. to
2:00 a.m. our hours because Dan Ariely
did summary is another researcher who
does quite interesting projects so he
looked at how likely are people to cheat
when they're sleep-deprived turns out
they're much more likely to cheat so if
you're looking at Excel spreadsheet and
in order to get to bonus you only need
to kind of tweak the formula a little
bit if you're if you're sleep-deprived
you're a lot more likely to do that all
of our bankers are sleep-deprived so
when you're studying you must sleep
enough it will maintain your mood and it
will also allow you to learn more
efficiently
every little counts if you have a task
that you absolutely hate like the other
day I had to apply for a grant
I hate applying for grants I hate
filling out stupid questions I just
don't do it so in situations like that
20 minutes might feel like too much pain
with Pomodoro so what you do you reduce
it to five minutes give yourself a time
limit do as much as you can in five
minutes then you can just drop the task
if you want to in this case you can
continue the point of this exercise is
to get started because once you've
actually started you feel that it
doesn't hurt so much so just may as well
continue it but first of all you
promised yourself five minutes and if it
still hurts you drop it afterwards you
may you may do another five minutes an
hour later but it doesn't feel like too
much pain and finally kill your
perfectionism you're not going to be
perfect I'm not perfect I started
learning data science half a year ago so
I'm not trying to compete with Andrea
however I'll know significantly more
than I did
half a year ago I can now teach people
about it and this has value so don't
expect to become an expert don't expect
to be able to I don't know humiliate
others because then you will be
humiliated yourself so this is not just
about expectation this is about modesty
if you're modest if you're not hoping to
become a Superman with your knowledge
then you're likely to have much more
realistic expectations and you're less
likely to suffer from perfectionism
which will kill your results
perfectionism doesn't let you get
started because then you want to achieve
so much that the fear of failure becomes
too high for you to even try now the N
word networking
everybody hates networking but obviously
since you're not doing a degree you will
need to somehow find your connections
you'll need to somehow find a job and
it's a lot easier to find work through
your social connections than through
applications online because those
applications are frequently sorted by an
algorithm if you don't have and the
algorithms will have features such as
does this person have a degree does this
person have a PhD No
discard you don't want to be sifted out
by a dumb machine before you even get to
talk to somebody you don't want to
cold-call people I've tried that I
worked as a recruitment agency for two
months it it's not pleasant and moreover
most people get annoyed and you tell and
they tell you to go away in harsher
terms so what you do instead is you make
friends now to a lot of people and we're
nerds by the way so we're introvert so
to a lot of people in the IT industry
networking is not pleasant because we've
always been taught that we need to go
and talk to people who don't really like
about something that they're interested
but we're not and then when you go into
a meeting like that into a networking
event it actually doesn't work because
your body language shows that you're not
interested in them that you bought so
the conversation stalls and everybody
ends up kind of uncomfortable and kind
of unhappy and no results so the key to
this is actually be selective don't try
to please somebody try to find your
in-group a group of people who are
actually
interested in the same things as you do
and go from there because you don't have
to start big obviously don't go to
comic-con and expect to find a job there
unless you are you know a professional
cosplayer but try to find the group that
belongs to that is related to your
industry to data science in my case and
go there and make friends go to events
that you're genuinely interested in and
express your opinions raise your hand
pester the presenter because then you
are noticed the say you will start
meeting the same people over and over
and you'll make friends and you'll find
jobs and you'll get connections so this
is what I did I signed up to a lot of
meetups and went to every single one of
them and I was genuine I didn't like I
didn't like all of them but I liked I
liked enough to make connections and to
meet people and to find people who I
could learn from who are who are
practicing data scientists who I asked
about oh how do I build a booster tree I
didn't know that at the time but they
told me and all you have to do in this
case is ask because if you're in the
right group of people you get the right
kind of support and also you start
signaling belonging to the in-group by
the virtue of having seen you around
repeatedly people will assume that you
belong even if you don't share all of
the characteristics of that group even
if you're not a data scientist yet if
they've seen you at a hundred meetups
they'll probably assume that you are so
they might come to you if they need a
new employee if they're looking for
somebody you signal belonging this is
the same this is the same thing that
your education would signal otherwise
and if you don't have a degree you need
to signal it by other means and also
create positive reinforcement so when
you talk to people you'll first of all
you'll figure out what works and what
doesn't you'll be able to ask questions
but also its pleasant its pleasant to
talk to people if you find the group
that you're interested in that the whole
point of the exercise is not to try and
be liked it's to find somebody who you
were who you will like because then
they'll like you in return
reciprocity people will tend to show
affection to those who show affection to
them and in any case this is still work
you're not going to like every single
meeting you're gonna go to you still
have to get up and schedule them and go
to them regularly because once in a
while you will you will get to one that
where you will meet somebody useful or
somebody you will like somebody who
likes you you get connections you get
jobs but don't expect every single one
to work perfectly just try to pick out
the ones that sound good to you and
obviously don't expect immediate results
you need to be seen multiple times you
need to develop your social skills until
it actually clicks all of a sudden and
it will not take one or two meetups it
will take maybe a month maybe two it
depends on what your existing level of
skills is by the way also it's also a
good idea to do things like
improvisation classes anything but a lot
or dancing class is anything that makes
you humiliate yourself or something that
you think will humiliate you in public
is good because then you're desensitized
to it then you're happy to go and talk
to 300 people then you're then you don't
care about somebody possibly not liking
you because otherwise if you are really
just really discouraged by every single
negative comment you might stop you
don't want that to happen you want to
desensitize yourself so resources what
did I actually do in technical terms and
I will post a lot there I have a very
long list which I will post on the slack
channel or possibly on the write-up for
the on the presentation page on the PI
data website so first of all meetups PI
data LM L P my meat of science journal
Reading Club googled them there is a
machine learning there is a machine
learning meetup as well there's a look
go go and meet meet up comm and machine
learning
to data science and you will see that
there are tens of those meetups and they
all meet quite regularly kind you can
very easily schedule one or two every
single week and go to them if you don't
find any that you like start one
yourself even better why I started my
meet-up two months ago now there's just
under eight hundred members so I get to
talk to a lot of people I get to pester
people who visit my my meetup if I have
any questions
Kegel and hackathons as soon as you have
the most basic knowledge like for
example ice I personally started with
Android Coursera course and machine
learning and I spent a month on that and
then the first thing I did afterwards
was do a Keagle competition it was the
Prudential competition and at the point
when I was starting it I didn't know are
at all so I had to learn our I did it by
looking at what other people submitted
in their code understanding how it works
debugging it getting it to run in my
computer then when it got when the code
got too slow to run on my computer
setting up a Google cloud server most
Google cloud virtual machine to run it
for me it all takes this is all learning
this is all things that you're gonna
have to do as a date as a practicing
data scientist and don't be discouraged
if you don't know if you don't know
something if you don't know Google it
copy somebody else's work see how it
works because textbooks will not contain
all of the advice package machine
learning packages don't have very good
documentation frequently as as you may
probably know looking at them yourself
so the best way to do something is to
practice if you can't find something on
Google then ask somebody off the creator
of the package ask on Stack Exchange and
people will answer those questions quite
happily this is how you write your own
textbook and this is by far the best
approach because it's it closely
approximates what you do as a working
data scientist and this is why you will
get an advantage
people who learned by via textbooks
because when I'm reading elements of
statistical learning it doesn't tell me
how to implement it how to put into
production it tells me about the
statistics underlying the algorithms and
the authors tries to advertise the
particular algorithms they made came up
with themselves which doesn't work very
well but they like it however when you
try to translate that into a career it
doesn't really work it's a reference
textbooks are a reference competitions
is where the actual learning happens
hackathons go find hackathons go to
there are some that deals specifically
with cattle competitions there are some
that try to deal with open source
datasets for example there was one at
UCL where they looked at NHS data and
try to find correlations within it
modeling it etc so try to find as many
practical events as you can and go to
them because you will make lots of
mistakes at first you will be extremely
slow it will be frustrating but you will
be learning and you will have to do that
anyway should you find work
Coursera there's plenty of free
resources so Coursera has the Stanford
course by and ruing it has a few others
related to machine learning look at
reviews look at what the course content
is pick the ones that you feel are most
useful for you
Udacity Udacity has a course intensive
flow which has been recently published
by in cooperation with Google so use
those resources they're there for you
and they're free know your stats data
science is based on statistics the
reason why I managed to transition into
data science so quickly is because it
didn't take me that much time to learn
the basic stats but then I didn't
remember them at the time I started my
my city the last time I did statistics
was four years before then when it was
in my year two and we had a lecturer who
gave us notes and we just filled out the
blanks with I didn't even show up to
half of the lecture so I didn't remember
it I didn't know what gamma function is
but moreover you will not need most of
the university statistics
because at the moment what stores at
university is even at a math degree
level is frequentist statistics and what
you need for data science is Bayesian
statistics you need updating you need to
update your expectations as you as you
see new evidence and this is not covered
by a lot of university courses so books
that I have looked at was elements of
statistical learning if it's a book by
Stanford professors an introduction to
statistical learning with applications
whether I think by the same guys a book
on statistics by James which I don't
remember the title off but it's very
easily go global I'll post it on the
slack or on the website later on and
finally pass to people if you're lost
then find somebody to ask this is why
you need the networking by the way so if
you go if you're working on a project
then you go to a meet-up find somebody
who might know something ask them for
their advice they'll point you somewhere
not necessarily in the right direction
but it will move you off the offer dead
spot and this is all you need sometimes
and that's where you learn a lot faster
than by googling the wrong their own
queries a lot of the time and finally
read the white papers so the blocks do
not contain state of the art
competitions do not contain state of the
art if you want to really understand
where you want to get to even if you
don't get those papers at first go to
the top companies go to a deep mind read
their white papers what what are they
doing go to Google Facebook look at what
they're publishing on data science and
machine learning look at the top people
in your field find out what they're
doing so that you know where where you
need to get to and also read those
papers repeatedly first time you read
them you may not understand them to why
two weeks down the line once you've
practiced a little bit you may
understand most of the paper third time
you understand all of it and this is
again how you learn finally don't get
started this might sound like
controversial
but when you're embarking on a large on
a complex project don't just jump in
don't burn your bridges immediately plan
first if you're a project manager who
has to I don't know
build an Eiffel Tower are they going to
decide okay we're starting tomorrow I
don't know where I'm gonna get the steel
from I don't know where I'm gonna get
the builders from where I'm gonna get
the machinery from I'm gonna start
tomorrow and I'll I know the budget
already I haven't asked anyone don't do
that so it took me about a year of
planning before actually well slightly
less than a year but about nine months
of planning before I actually left my
job and I felt I was ready to embark on
this so make sure you know what where
you're actually aiming this is the key
that allows you to get there fast
because then you have the exact metrics
by which to assess your learning the
same as you would assess a learning
algorithm you need to have a loss
function you to have a cost function how
do you know because if you don't know
where you're going you don't know how
far you've gone either and yes you need
the right questions where are you going
so question time
yes hi that was great how would you
suggest people in industry design
interviews in order to pick out the
really good data scientists since you've
put a lot of thought into thinking about
the different routes to get there
this is actually an Avenue I considered
myself as a career developing algorithms
for so this is this is the answer apply
data science to it because you do not
know look at fools of your candidates
pick out the ones that actually
performed well run some linear
regression on it see see which
characteristics stand out because one
thing you are constantly reminded of
when you're doing data Sciences do not
make assumptions and what is generally
made by people doing interviews is
assumptions okay we're assuming that if
he has a PhD he's going to be good we're
assuming that if he smiles a lot and
looks like looks generally Pleasant that
he's going to be a good employee and not
a skill sociopath so so don't expect
that what's on the face value is going
to allow you to determine what's
actually underneath but if you look at
one of the first slides you can look at
this paper so work sample tests make
sure to get a practical question into
your interview see how the person does
it how they approach it even if they
take it home get them to talk through it
that this this will show you how they
work as simply is that if they don't if
you don't expect them to know how to
work yet look at their IQ look at how
other people talk about them ask them a
question and see how they approach
answering it so but more importantly
employment interviews have to be
structured
so if you read all of this paper then
you will see that unstructured
interviews are significant
because they do not gather the same kind
of information about every single
applicant so if you don't know if you
don't know what you're comparing on
you're not able to compare therefore you
just get biased by whether the
interviewer was in a good mood on the
day kind of thing but it will all be
industry dependent so the best and even
company dependent so the best approach
is to look at your own pool of
applicants and successful employees and
what is similar between those thank you
what was your percentage salary change
from the previous job the new job
okay so I work for a start-up my person
at the moment I'm not being paid a
salary however as of the day before
yesterday we got quarter of a million in
funding and another quarter of a million
coming up my terms mean that I start at
50% of my market value which means the
same salary as they had before I quit
and that's will increase sorry yes yes
so I have a vesting I have a vesting
agreement
I hold the equity but I also take lower
salary because of that but I do I am
starting at the same level as I quit
generally they did research people who
people who go into entrepreneurial
avenues and who don't actually just try
to freelance who are involved either in
a start-up or in their own business end
up gaining about on average 30% compared
to their corporate salary so if you quit
and if you did well in your old job you
tend to do better in your new job
however if you quit because you just
don't want to boss and you want to work
from home and for a four hours a day
then most likely you will lose in salary
because this is a different type of
self-employed person
hi that was that was amazing
one thing that like stands out a sort of
a term that you didn't use in this is
contributions to some open source stuff
which is contributions to open source
yes so for instance having does it
matter having a get get up sort of
profile that sort of like shows that you
have been contributing to some of the
some of the libraries I guess that are
being used in the industry so what's the
question so what do you think about that
I mean so that it doesn't appear in your
presentation does it does it matter yes
the question so the question is does it
matter
showing your contributions to open
source stuff yes it does
so this is some this is one way to
signal just to signal your belonging to
the in-group essentially LinkedIn who
you're connected to is another way of
signaling your belonging
writing blog posts about relevant stuff
is another way of signaling so my way of
doing that is sharing my knowledge back
through my Meetup so all of these things
are equivalent if you're able to share
you're showing that you own the
knowledge that you're sharing whether
it's through github or through
publishing papers or through teaching
other people it doesn't matter you can
always choose your own way of doing it
but sharing means that you own more than
you have to give away
so how important were mentors for you
for you on your journey did you have had
people that supported you how important
were my mentors yes a lot of people were
supporting me but most but I had to find
those people myself I didn't start with
the support group I started obviously my
partner was all for it she was cheering
me up but he is not a data scientist he
is a filmmaker so I didn't understand
who supported you I said my boyfriend my
partner so I got obviously support from
my family and friends but I didn't get
any technical support until I found it
and I didn't have any people from the
outset who I could ask all of my
questions so that's why it started
socializing eventually this is through
pestering people is how I got my job and
this is how I got my fellowship to do AI
research in the States this summer so if
and the reason I got my fellowship is
because I wrote a comment on Luke mill
Hauser's blog post where he asked people
interested in AI safety research to
deluxe and to show themselves so I did
and then they sent me an invitation for
the fellowship application so I applied
in so I go it got in so if you don't ask
you don't get final question
I'm sorry if the final question sounds a
bit off topic but I can't help but come
back to the theory by which education is
is a way of signaling which is a theory
but it's certainly not how education was
was invented in some sense yes and
that's probably the first time in my
life I see presentation about work a job
which has scientific name and which
passion is not mentioned at all which
doesn't explain why I spent three years
of my PhD with a low salary with not
many more job opportunities maybe
because of my choices and I would do it
again okay so could you repeat your
question please
passion doesn't play any role in doing
this kind of work yes of course
passion plays a role in doing PhDs and
those PhDs who apply and do their pieces
because they're passionate about their
subject and have researched the
supervisors and have picked the
supervisors who they like and are doing
the subject they're genuinely interested
in those ones succeed but that's not the
maturity I'm afraid most people who
apply for peds do it as a continuation
of their undergrad they do it because
it's expected and if you do something if
you go into a three-year project not
knowing what you want to do and ending
up doing something you're completely not
interested in you're not going to gain
much value out of that because well you
won't have an incentive to dig in deeper
to become a true expert in the subject
I'm not discouraging people from doing
PhD is what I'm saying is that no what
you're actually doing and unfortunately
there aren't that many PhDs available in
the field of machine learning with
genuinely interesting subjects where you
are able to contribute those are few and
far between and you need funding for
those so yes thank you yes exactly yes
well as I as I said those who are doing
it because they're passionate about the
subject succeed those who are doing it
because they think they should be doing
it do not that's the main I'm not I'm
not discrediting PhD as a concept I'm
discrediting the approach this banker
Tatiana for showing us this one many
paws